sonic has run through city streets  tropical jungles and sandy deserts and  now he'll be running onto the big screen  Sega's chief executive Hajime Saito  confirmed that his company is working  with Sony Pictures to create a Sonic the  Hedgehog movie it's said to be a hybrid  of live-action and animation we caught  wind of this back in 2014 but now we  know it's hitting theaters in 2018 this  year marks the 25th anniversary of the  Sonic series so expect plenty of  announcements if this official Sonic  tweet is any indication Sega has more up  its sleeve fingers crossed for something  other than sonic boom  despite releasing a fancy new logo last  month  Sega hasn't confirmed any new games to  commemorate the blue blurs birthday the  next scheduled title is sonic boom Fire  and Ice for 3ds for now all we know is  that a movie is on its way stay tuned to  game spot for more